we won't have our teleporters whenever
you hear in the popular press about
experiments involving quantum
teleportation what they're really
transmitting is information and not
actual atoms or people or anything like
that so that won't be coming one thing
that is coming is electrons that we use
in our transistors and we grab hold of
them with the electric charge that they
have and pull them with voltages and
electric fields every electron also has
a little built-in magnetic field
actually every proton every Neutron all
matter has an intrinsic angular momentum
or spin and in that in four massive
particles that manifest in them having a
little built-in magnetic field as well
scientists are working on using that
magnetic field in addition to the
electric charge to manipulate the
electrons since the magnetic field in
quantum mechanics derives from a
quantity called spin these devices have
been called spintronics as opposed to
just simple electronics and if that
comes to fruition if it fulfills its
promise what you will have is is
integrated circuits and devices that do
both data manipulation and data storage
at the same time in the same place so
believe it or not the computers can even
get smaller and that might be coming
pretty soon another thing that I think
might be coming is an analog of solar
cells solar cells another term for them
is photovoltaics from from photo from
light and voltaic stew create a voltage
there are devices called thermal
electrics they take temperature
differences and they create voltages and
when you have a solid-state refrigerator
that has no coolant but can cool say a
single bottle of wine um these devices
use thermoelectrics there right now
they're not very efficient and so you
could use them for these small little
applications but nothing large-scale
scientists are working on making these
devices better and improving their
efficiency there's a lot of waste heat
underneath the hood of your car that
right now is just going off and warming
up the atmosphere and does nothing as
far as local motion is concerned but if
these devices improved in their quality
we can use that waste heat recapture
some of that energy use it to recharge
the battery say in your hybrid
automobile and so in the future the cars
may not fly but they'll get much better
mileage